[Musique]
monsieur sarr je vous fait combien de
kilomètres par jour comme ça environ
10 15 20 km
et vous commencez à quelle heure et
commencer à quelle heure
cependant je me lève
et se couche trop tard des fois je me
laisse un peu aller au lit
ça vous faire terminer vers
8 heures les bons jours 10 heures les
mauvais
alors qu'elles seraient connus en 22'
pavillon center et 22h à quelle
fréquence passez-vous dans les villages
que le public toutes les semaines
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais pas par la porte de l'abbaye
je n'aime pas que ce qu'a fait vite un
litre de lait
un café ces acheteurs sont surtout des
femmes la plupart du temps oui bon je
dois encore dans la semaine
jeannerod chansons
plus les jambes pour pas été recensés
hier
[Applaudissements]
celui qui tout seul il achète et le gars
qui vient faire là les courses pour ça
pour ça pour l'oise alors là il ya
toujours plus propre est en droit de
penser c'est pas la joie
mais en principe vaut mieux avoir une
femme tout seul
combien j'ai couru de l'année du
foyer sont selon
vous les connaissez par leur nom aux
clients oui même les prénoms parce que
on connaît plus facilement le prénom que
le nom parce que la
cliente en fait quand il ya toujours
qu'il y est ensemble on positionne même
village s'appelle pas la pression et on
met bien plus forts à savoir le nombre
parce que je remplis j'ai pas de voir si
peu à l'ordinateur
de quoi parlez vous avec vos clients en
général
de la pluie du beau temps on blague
quelques opérations dépendent des
caractères de chaque client il faut
adapter la chose selon
les besoins de la cause
le chant sont alors avec une blague
comme l'histoire on chante ça se produit
entrez entrez et vous verrez la femme
sans tête qui se grattent les cheveux
après un trailer
est envoyée ruse
et axa qui
vous est fait des amis vous voyant dans
votre commerce dans les vos clients on
n'a pas le temps on a peu de temps dans
les prix 24 heures sur 24 n'ont pas le
temps de faire des amis
royal a toujours quelques journaux
environ quand comme ça quand tu as un
contexte aussi
d'accord n'en fallut pas jalouse quand
même
une aide pas inquiète de savoir votre
mari constamment sur les routes comme ça
pas du tout même par tous les temps ao
quelquefois s'y rendent très tard le
soir je m'inquiète un petit peu alors je
donne un petit coup de téléphone
dans un village où il doit finir la
tournée quelque forme dit il est arrivé
où il vient juste de partir m'enfin je
le fais rarement pour pas déranger les
clients quand même
vous ne retournais jamais mangé chez
vous alors quand vous êtes en tournée
simplement le mercredi et pourquoi ça
parce que je suis sur place
je tourne autour de
2 chez nous quoi
je rentre lui mercredi et pourquoi vous
ne mangez pas chez vous les autres fois
parce que c'est trop loin enfin c'est
trop loin de voir le corps de peu le
chômage et 9 km pour y rentrer pour
garder n'est ce qu'elle pourra venir
alors là je suis très bien la balle et
ça mon brouillon il est pas tout
vous aimez être seul j'ai l'impression
quand on a vu les clients toute la
journée et tout le matin vous savez le
vin tranquille un peu de radio j'ai
connu deux formations
2 c'est vrai que ce sont bien des
appétits mon point de vue à ce qu'ils
voudront et
combien d'habitants ici 32 e environ
alors comment faites vous pour vous
approvisionner eh ben on fait comme on
peut heureusement qu'on a des chars
normes us marshall qui vient autrement
vous savez faire 5 km pour aller
chercher un pde macaroni au vert qu'est
ce que vous appréciez le plus chez votre
marchand ambulant ont pas et ça marche
en dise n'est pas mal et maîtrisé le
très aimable plaisanté avec lui à la rue
on
aurait tort qu'est ce que vous lui
raconter alors votre vie un peu on envie
non ça ne regarde pas première non non
le faire enrager voilà les miens surtout
pour nos porte monnaies dit qu'il aime
les femmes nous autres on lui dit oui
c'est le portefeuille voilà vous avez
connu d autres marchands ambulants avant
ah oui comment comment ça se passait à
l'époque c'est l'éclaté motorisés comme
ça oui camions et tout je vais même vu
dans le temps j'étais jeune c'était des
chiens qui traînait une petite remorque
[Musique]
on
dirait un petit peu et comme tout bon
limousin ont fait son petit chapeau à
ces coûts ne sais pas ça vous alors
qu'est ce que c'est chabrol ça c'est du
bouillon bien chaud avec une bonne
rasade répit là dedans on savoir ça
derrière la calade
il s'attend maintenant à mon vieux
et financier de calotin attention et le
boire à l'assiette ca c c'est primordial
qu'est ce que vous appréciez le plus
dans un marchand ambulant bas vous savez
est ce que le conduisent ça nous rend
bien service parce qu'il passa sur place
alors ça nous invite bien de partir soit
juillac soit ailleurs ce double et
surtout l'hiver vous avez fait très
mauvais litres / à domicile fois les
prix sont pas exagérés si on va dans des
supermarchés on sent mis souvent de
beaucoup de choses et on a beaucoup plus
de points que de que d'acheter à notre
marchand qui passe à la campagne
finalement vous pensez que c'est plus
intéressant d'acheter un non violent je
pense pas que c'est plus intéressant
mais je trouve que c'est un peu plus
faire et quoi je crois pas qu'on ait
beaucoup plus de frais que d'aller dans
un grand supermarché ou autre et si on
ira ainsi pendant de la qualité si ça
nous plaît parle lui la semaine d'après
on a quand même cet avantage de pouvoir
se plaindre qu'est ce qui vous plaît
surtout dans ce métier au tout tout seul
contact humain qui a on a un contact
enfin comme comme avérés
les petits magasins dans le temps dans
la campagne qui était dans le village là
où il
y avait un contact humain on connaissait
sa clientèle moi je connais toutes mes
clientes moi je n'ai pas plus ne fait
pas ça n'est pas plus que celle lâche
pas comme le supermarché qui connaît ces
anonymes mais moi je fais toutes mes
clientes et
ma femme vous dira oui bon
il sait qu'à part les femmes d'accord
des fois je sais pas vous savez de la
jeune et pas loin là
c'est quoi
c'est un peu coincé des fois non mais
c'est vrai mais il s'agit je crois qu'il
s'agit de ça va aller prendre une fois
qu'on a dit ça y est classée l'ambiance
est là dedans au pelage envie de son sac
la bonne femme là ras-le-bol est le vide
et puis ça y est
c'est moi qui les ramasse et quoi je
puisse à la poche gauche emporte une
pile c'est terminé si françois s'en
faut bien
vous arrive de rencontrer des gens des
mêmes familles dans des endroits
différents oui aulas en cela la c c'est
quelque chose de spécial parce qu'il
faut
c'est ce qui a été dur pour moi c'était
le début de ce que j'étais pas licite je
connaissais pas les liens de parenté au
faire très attention dans ces cas là
parce que il faut faire pas dire de mal
de quelqu'un
et ont mis à beaucoup y en a qui sont
ceux ci c'est une une chaîne sans fin on
entend partout alors ils vous disent du
mal de l'ordre et puis finalement ben
ils sont tous parents alors dans ces cas
là tu tu étouffes une route vers gaza
parce qu'ils sont venus ont tous parents
ils sont ils sont brouillées aujourd'hui
ils sont ils sont d'accord de 20 et puis
on perd mais plusieurs fois le concorde
et
j'avais beaucoup de marchands ambulants
qui passent ici pour pratiquement pas
tellement
et autre fois il ya toujours eu des
marchands qui passait comme ça il ya eu
des mots chi minh en glace plus et
pourquoi ça parce qu'il est décédé alors
il n'a pas trouvé de clients pour
intention n'est pas de remplaçant à vous
êtes obligé de vous déplacer rien moby
génial à cette option vous avez une
voiture si vous n'aviez nom n'a pas de
voiture accor en fait mon mari qui va
mobile est ce soir
à la tombée de la nuit je vais trouver
une main 85 ans
la boîte nommée
un peu soudain bien
mais bien
qu'elle va me dire des vous voyez une
verrée ma fille demande alors la fille
la vingtaine mois
et
elle a toujours des bricoleurs un paquet
de gâteaux des illustrés à cette
industrie des femmes d'aujourd'hui
dimanche à 11h pour quad et de la
lecture saluant moi parce que la fille
ella
ella une ferme nous occuper
du napperon des rides ou parce que le
crochète magnifiquement alors toutes les
semaines un peu près je fais le courrier
alors je vois la fille de même et demain
je connais salafiya six heures du soir
rien à voir il va bien ah bon ça va mais
ça va
bon ben sylla la fille pavé janvier abus
de l'écrire comme cette année je me
savais il faut lui écrire parce que ça
me remet ça c'est ce à quoi
une chose qui m'a qui m'a frappé c'est
que vous vendez à la campagne vous
vendez des produits de la campagne par
exemple des poireaux comment expliquer
une salle
où nombre d'êtres réalise vous avez vu
le temps qu'il fait il a gelé les pois
rouge sur la tête haute ils sont série
un bon intermédiaire dessus qu'est ce
qui reste le vert dans la main le bras
et dans la terre
elles peuvent arracher le poireau donc
moi je vends des travaux dans quelques
jours quand ça va déjouer ce soit fini
et qu'on se fait t'il aussi que vous
vendiez du lait aussi du lait stérilisé
d'une émotion la publicité
les jardins télévision le lait stérilisé
chez très bon demi écrémé d'accord
meilleur pour les artères et tout ça
usant des bêtes oui n'ont pas le temps
de traire ou alors il ya des gens qui
préfèrent du les duvets industrielle au
lait frais même qui le produisent
eux-mêmes
[Applaudissements]
comment disposer vous vos produits sur
vos étalages c'est pas par hasard je
suppose mais ça ça a été une étude
surtout de ma femme et de ma fille la
seconde qui ont installé le camion quand
elles ont gardé un mois dans les mains l
europe l intérieur tout arranger et puis
alors selon ce qui se voit ce qui se
vend pas avait étudié aujourd'hui
longtemps le problème c'est de loger
tous les articles
allez fais le plein du camion tout alors
qu'est-ce que tu en as i m
et puis arrivé au bout mais la mère
n'est plus de place il manquait encore
deux articles en entier ça encore et
qu'elle n'aura pas il reste le foutoir
comme ça il ya des choses qu'il faut
avoir il faut tous logés dans la dalle
dans la je sais pas combien je dois
avoir vu mètre carré je crois même pas
si lui et de caricature de ces bons
d'état us karim est faux que jose tout
ce qui a un
il ya des gens qui vous passent des
commandes aussi
moi
je m'occupe pas de ça c'est la
bourgeoise qui s'occupe de tout ça et
puis oui
livres ce qui m'intéresse c'est que le
soir
mon mari m'a téléphoné il faut que je
lui porte de la marchandise il manque de
certaines choses un peu de vin du
fromage
et fromages frais aussi alors vous
n'arrêtez jamais pas souvent il ya
toujours eu des marchands ambulants qui
sont venus oui quand il faille
avec des voiles et régler ma chaîne et à
en faire et où khalifa il vient de vous
vendre à domicile mais oui et tout le
temps de tout temps de tout temps le
califat d'un bref assez
et les épiciers démarrer les marchands
pour la pour la nourriture ont
maintenant on va faire les gens ici
c'est pas loin des débours et
c'est pas grave il est là il y avait le
planteur issa
quant au califat dans le temps oui et
comment il était temps camion aussi
comment il était en camion aussi dans le
temps il avait une loi comme une machine
3 et puis on prend les matches les gens
à marcher à pied il allait aux foires
sais pas quand mais maintenant
maintenant les gens
il faut que le marché revienne chez bwin
émergents on voyait bien que vous devez
faire servir à domicile
non mais tu en avais pas domicile comme
ça va me chercher on est content je
trouve quelqu'un qui arrive
aujourd'hui vous défendre une tannée
malades dans les vieux alors n'est ce
pas un peu pas il est content que les
gens reviennent dans les campagnes comme
ça et vous pouvez continuer à faire ce
métier là jusqu'à quand je ne sais pas
je me suis jamais cassé la tête pour
savoir j'ai toujours eu du boulot qu'est
ce qui vous plaît le plus dans ce métier
mais à vous personnellement
la liberté je pense d'être libre parce
que j'ai des heures qui sont
certainement
elles ne sont pas content et parce que
les gens nagent en fait beaucoup mais si
je veux me blairer j'ai des enfants qui
sont au lycée 6 en après midi j'ai une
réunion avec les professeurs je peux me
permettre de dire cet après midi je vais
aller au lycée et puis de même j'en
mettrais un petit coup de plus pour
rattraper le temps perdu mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas de patrons nous arrive de
prendre des vacances de temps en temps
oui au rebond mais ça arrive
[Musique]